David all these years of being in
entertainment whether it's a magician a
comic writer why now with your latest
project which is all be next door for
Christmas how long did it take you to
think of it to actually get it on paper
to then want to cast for it what was the
well I was raising I want to make an
interpretive film I could direct and I
was raising money for another movie
that's much more expensive like a four
or five billion dollar movie and I was
just going through all the processes of
talking to rich people glaze it but the
film company is doing all the things you
have to do to raise that kind of money
and it was really difficult so I thought
you know I want to try to be smart about
this I'm going to write a low-budget
movie so that I can raise the money more
easily and make this movie then after
that we'll do the bigger one so I
specifically came up with this Christmas
movie for business reasons and artistic
reasons the artistic reasons are LM
Christmas movies I mean they're really
fun they're all about Christmas being in
jeopardy and the family driving each
other crazy but they come through
stronger in the end they're just really
fun to watch and the good ones get a
little really get sentimental at the end
but they get there in a way that they
earned it you know and so I enjoy that
and the second reason we're business
reasons Christmas movies sell okay
there's a million of them on cable they
always sell there's a big demand for
them and the studio's don't make them
they make very few of them now they make
one every couple of years or so and so
they're in the business of making
student the major studios make sequels
prequels prequel to the sequels and you
have comic books movies and things like
that that's their business they'll make
150 million dollar movie spend $200
marketing it and make 800 million
dollars on it and that's it's a great
business model but the independent
producers are filling in the vacuum of
the small character driven movie the
comedy and family Christmas comedies
just aren't made that often specially
witty ones and so I thought for business
purposes
this this is going to sell and because
it's a Christmas movie it's going to
sell year after year after year a
Christmas story was made in 1983 and it
still makes a ton of money every season
can people buy it and give it as a DVD
people stream it get it on cable it's it
holds up Christmas movies if you'll
forgive the pun Christmas movies are
evergreen they're forever people still
watch It's a Wonderful Life from 70
years ago and still has an income stream
for the studio so that's one of the
reasons I decided to make the Christmas
movies people provide income for the
producers and the investors for decades
to come
that's the idea so that was one of the
business reasons and also I wanted to do
it low budget and so I wrote the movie
specifically that way if you want to
write a low-budget movie right for what
you've got or what you can get cheaply
okay
don't write big explosions that's you
know there's no there's no there's no
digital effects in our movie nothing
like that no expensive post-production
it's a character driven comedy okay and
the plot of the movie is
sixteen-year-old girl her parents have
ruined her life with Christmas their
Christmas crazy drives her nuts she's
got a boyfriend the first love of her
life he's coming to visit her at
Christmas she doesn't want to subject
him to a crazy family so she does what
any teenager do she hires two actors to
play her parents and has a fake
Christmas dinner for her boyfriend of
the empty house next door who among us
has not done that anyway what could go
wrong right so most of the movie takes
place at two houses right next door to
each other so we can set up the crew we
can set up the location and we don't
have to move for four weeks now
I'm sure La Vie audience knows that when
you're making a film the less you have
to travel you know the more money you
can save the more time you say so I set
it up that way to be contained you know
there's a couple of scenes outside there
but most of it takes place right there
at those houses right next door to each
other also when you write it have two
characters in most of the scenes if you
have three four five six seven
characters every character in that scene
that's another character you got a cover
you got to get footage of that character
every time we do that takes more time so
how
a lot of scenes with just two characters
if you have kids and pets in the movie
and ours in the Christmas movie so there
are you know some kids and at a cat
named parsley and they're only in the
cats only in two scenes and it doesn't
do any tricks people just start carrying
it that's it okay and the kids the
little kids are only in about six or
seven scenes that's another way save
money if you have stuff that's going to
take time to do
don't write a lot of scenes for it okay
so there are a lot of tricks and things
you can do to write a low-budget movie
so that you can shoot it well because if
you're writing above your budget level
then you're going to be making so many
compromises less than right that the
movie is just going to suffer I mean you
know that's there's only so many hours
in the day to shoot you know actors can
only work so lucky today and the other
thing is if you write a good character
driven comedy or any kind of character
German piece you attract better actors
because you're given them something good
and they can sink their teeth into that
they want to do so those are all the
elements
artistic elements that I wrote
specifically into the movie that were
driven by business decisions and you
have jennifer Tilly attached we have
Jennifer Tilly yes very cool added about
that she's a oscar-nominated for
Broadway for arms up for bullets over
Broadway with Woody Allen and she tells
great Woody Allen stories very funny
stories while working with him and yet
she's got a Chucky movie coming out
right now hey fun Chucky movies she also
a poker champion she's won several poker
championships yes yes I played hooker
with her wow she's really good that's
basically it's a poker lesson playing
with her but yeah Jennifer Tilly's
attached to play the woman who owns the
house next door that the kids staged the
fake Christmas dinner in so she's great
to work with she's uh she's such good
comedic timing always makes the joke
work always makes the script better than
it actually is a we love actors they do
that make us look like geniuses Thank
You Jennifer so how did you get the
script tore I was working on a TV show
I came up with her and she was in the
cast and I came up to her after at a rap
party and said to hi and said can I give
you a script for a movie that I'm doing
and I don't mean to be obnoxious and I
you know I assure you give us all the
time I was saying it like half
apologetically and she stopped me and
she goes sure and sure give it to me I
was very sweet and thankfully she liked
the script and that's I just I just
walked up to her and wasn't creepy just
some cuts but yeah the mighty guy yeah I
mean after remember two actors need
material they need projects they need to
do things too so if you approach them in
a respectful businesslike way then you
know if you act like you have something
they might want and maybe he'll take a
look at it I've had good success with
that actually just I'm saying hi
you